we're returning now to breaking news
we're getting from Iraq we've been
hearing reports of drones and a rocket
attack on the anal Assad Airbase that
hosts Us and other International forces
in Western Iraq according to the Reuters
news agency multiple blasts were heard
inside the base as we've been saying ANL
Assad is located in the western anba
Province let's bring in Patty Khan she
has more for us now from Washington DC
Patty this is obviously a fast
developing story what more details do we
have now
well we know that we're waiting to hear
from the Pentagon The Briefing was
supposed to start it's just usually a
regular briefing about 45 minutes ago
and then pushed it back 15 minutes
pushed it back another half an hour it
should be starting any moment of course
we'll hopefully get more information
from there but this is exactly what the
US has been concerned about it has about
2500 troops in Iraq scattered around the
country this is so sorry to interrupt
you um timely the Pentagon press
conference has in indeed now just begun
let's listen in know of to any civilians
on the ground information about these
engagements is still being processed and
we cannot say for certain what these
missiles and drones were targeting but
they were launched from Yemen heading
north along the Red Sea potentially
towards Targets in Israel our defensive
response was one that we would have
taken for any similar threat in the
region where we're able to do so against
our interest personnel and our partners
this attack may be ongoing so if we have
more information to share we will
but again as the secretary has made
clear we have the capability to defend
our broader interests in the region and
to deter Regional escalation and broader
expansion of the conflict that began
with hamas's attack on Israeli CI
civilians on October 7th the crew of the
Carney did just that and across the
force we will remain Vigilant to any
other potential
threats and while I'm on the topic of
threats let me provide an update on the
reports of several drone attacks against
us facilities in Iraq and Syria
early yesterday morning Syria time
October 18th The utop Garrison in Syria
was targeted by two drones us and
Coalition forces engaged one drone
destroying it while the other drone
impacted the base resulting in minor
injuries to Coalition
forces also the same morning in Iraq
early Warning Systems indicated a
possible threat approaching the air base
at al-assad and base Personnel sheltered
in place as a protective measure though
no attack occurred sadly a US civilian
contractor suffered a cardiac episode
while Sheltering and passed away shortly
thereafter and our deepest sympathies
and condolences are with the loved one
loved ones of the individual who passed
away and as you know the day before on
October 17th US military forces defended
against three drones near us and
Coalition forces in Iraq in Western Iraq
at al-assad Airbase US forces engaged
two drones destroying one and damaging
the second resulting in minor injuries
to Coalition forces
separately in Northern Iraq US forces
engaged and destroyed a drone near
Basher Airbase resulting in no injuries
or damage and while I'm not going to
forecast any potential response to these
attacks I will say that we will take all
necessary actions to defend us and
Coalition forces against any threat any
response should one occur will come at a
time and a manner of our choosing now in
light of all of this activity secretary
Austin continues to actively engage with
his counterparts and leaders within the
Middle East today he conducted a series
of calls which included discussions With
His Highness president shik Mohamad bin
Zed of the United Arab Emirates Amir
shik tamim of Qatar and Saudi Arabia
Minister of Defense khed bin Salman Al
secretary Austin also spoke with Israeli
Minister of Defense y Galant just a few
moments ago and during these calls he
reiterated us support for Israel's right
to defend itself from terrorist attacks
and also underscored the importance of
safeguarding innocent civilians both
Palestinian and Israeli he emphasized
again that any country or any group
thinking about trying to take advantage
of the situation in Israel to try to
widen the conflict should think twice
and not doubt the resolve of the United
States it is our aim to avoid any
Regional expansion of Israel's conflict
with Hamas but we stand ready and
prepared to protect and defend our
partners and our interests and we will
act to do so readouts of these calls
will be posted to the dod website later
today and with respect to us support to
Israel the first shipments of military
aid including Munitions began arriving
in Israel last week and continue to
arrive on a near daily basis this
assistance is comprised of capabilities
requested by Israel to include Precision
guided Munitions such as joint direct
attack Munitions small diameter bombs
155 mm artillery ammunition and other
categories of critical equipment in
addition Iron Dome interceptors from
stocks that the United States has in
country have been quickly provided to
Israel and in the days ahead we'll be
flowing additional Iron Dome
interceptors so that Israel has the
capabilities they need to to sustain
their iron doome defense systems and
protect their CI citizens and cities
from rocket
attacks we will leverage several Avenues
available to us to include our stocks
and Industry channels that reinforce the
United States unwavering and iron clad
support for both the Israeli Defense
Forces and the Israeli people as always
the Department of Defense will continue
to support plan and undertake these
critical missions professionally and
with the inherent right to protect our
force and with that I will be happy to
take your questions we'll start with ap
tarot thank you General Ryder could you
also talk about uh apparently there's a
new round of attacks at Al Assad that is
occurring either now or has happened
today do you have any information on
that yeah thanks Tara um I've seen uh
some reporting on that uh I don't have
any details to provide right now but
certainly uh as more information becomes
available we'll pass that along and then
more generally as this violence has
uptick since the hospital bombing um
what protection measures are you taking
particularly like for the forces in onom
where there's been so much activity over
the years as Fighters have tried to move
weapons and people
towarda yeah certainly uh we take Force
protection extremely seriously uh and we
will continue to do so I'm not going to
get into specific Force protection me
measures other than uh again when we
have forces In Harm's Way we're going to
look at all possible uh efforts to
ensure that they uh remain safe and are
able to to stay focused on their on
their mission so this is something that
we'll continue to monitor um but again
um we are going to take Force protection
very seriously but can you say like
you've strengthened or taken additional
Force protection measures and are you
seeing more activity more drone activity
like in the last couple days than you
have you know for the last few months
and we are certainly taking appropriate
Force protection measures to to ensure
the safety of our troops uh again I'm
not going to get into specifics uh
clearly uh this is an uptick in terms of
the types of drone activity we've seen
uh in Iraq and Syria um but again um
yeah I'll just leave it at that thank
you well you've been listening there to
a press conference from the Pentagon
confirming that us warship shot down
three missiles and drones in the
northern Red Sea Brigadier General Pat
Ryder the pentagon's press secretary
who's been speaking also described
incidents that have recently taken place
in Iraq and Syria but gave no further
details on the ANL Assad attacks that
were reported just in the last hour or
so let's now go back to Patty Khan in
Washington DC Patty um he mentioned an
uptic in drone activity and I know the
Pentagon is also saying that the
Secretary of Defense has been engaging
with Gulf lead leers how real are the
threats of well fears of
escalation they are very real in fact I
think that you saw right at the
beginning of this conflict between Gaza
and Israel uh that the US sent an
aircraft carrier directly to the Eastern
Med they then sent another carrier group
the US's Eisenhower which was scheduled
to to deploy anyway so now they're going
to have two aircraft carriers in the med
they haven't really done that since the
Iraq War was very much active so it is
and there're also sending a command and
control ship uh that's normally based in
Italy to be in that General region so
that is how the US projects force with
aircraft carriers now I found it very
notable that he's not talking about what
we're hearing is happening currently in
Iraq no mention of it uh and the fact
that they kept this quiet we did not
know about the attacks in Syria uh that
they engaged one and another one hit the
base in Syria we know that they've been
very hypervigilant there because of some
of the attacks that turkey's been taking
taking place that the USS is too close
to their forces they have about 900 uh
forces in Syria about 2500 in Iraq and
we did know that two different uh bases
in Iraq yesterday were hit by drones uh
uh and he's obviously just confirming
that but this is the concern the US does
not want to be uh dragged into a wider
War uh and it is something that the
American people would very much not want
and Joe Biden very much wants to be
president again
uh so he's they're trying to strike this
balance project strength hope it deters
because I think it's pretty clear that
this is not something that the US wants
to engage in but at the same time
offering a full-throated support of
Israel so the US President Joe Biden is
giving a Primetime speech tonight to lay
out why he thinks it's important to give
Aid to Ukraine and Ira and uh Israel
it'll be interesting to see if these
attacks work his way into his speech
because this is something that again the
American people do not after the
of AF of Afghanistan and Iraq they do
not want to see the US dragged into
another conflict uh py as you were
referencing as well this obviously isn't
the first attack just this week on NL
Assad can you give us a sense of how
critical a base it is for us operations
and and do we have any sense of who
might want to Target
it uh you know obviously the fear is
that it's Iran backed uh mil militias
that's obviously going to be the fear
because what's the concern a US Iranian
War uh and so they're probably looking
at that they're not pointing the finger
here in the US at that just just yet I
know our correspondent in Baghdad said
that some Iranian back groups had
claimed responsibility um it is a very
important base uh there are again 2500
troops in US troops in Iraq they are
scattered across the country um and of
course you know there's a very long
history at that air base but the fact
that they are saying that one of the
drones was able to get in in Syria and
caused some uh some injuries that's
unusual usually when American troops are
injured they give a little bit more
detail than that so it's very clear that
the Pentagon is trying to limit the
communication of this uh they will not
want to alarm the American public
because uh a recent poll I read said uh8
in 10 Americans are very much worried
that this is going to lead to a broader
conflict uh and so Americans are paying
attention to this so I think that could
explain why you're hearing so few
details so many late details from the
Pentagon very interesting Dynamics Patty
khh there with the latest for us from
Washington DC thank you so much passy